[Music]
at the high school or high school
musical wish I had never staged a
production of high school musical the
musical I was shocked
inspired and triggered as a millennial
[Music]
auditions are after school I've seen
their original movie 37 times and the
first 15 minutes of those sequels it
would be insane to think I might
actually have a shot at playing
Gabriella I know we're not a couple
anymore
it was my idea to take a pause I didn't
want to take a pause I can't believe it
she's dating each eighth husband this is
a nightmare
I want audition for Gabriella Ryan right
I think you'd rather play sure pay that
is so fresh I'm bummed that we don't
have any competition here she has to see
me in a whole new light I'm auditioning
for this thing tomorrow and nothing is
gonna stop me the cast list is posted we
have our Gabriella and our Troy buckle
up Wildcats it's about to get real
I basically have zero chill about this
right half
[Music]
what are you doing here if she really
cared about me you'd let somebody who
wants to play this part play
you all walked in here as strangers but
after today you're a family I believe
Nuss
[Music]
excuse me is there some where you're
supposed to be Broadway
[Music]